we're stuck waiting for final fantasy 15
until sep tember 30th but that's not the
only FF game coming this year final
fantasy brave x vs has already racked up
six million downloads in japan and now
it's coming West the free mobile game
will be released sometime this summer
brave ex vyas is co-developed by square
enix and gummy inc and it's the
turn-based RPG you expect from the final
fantasy series you'll take control of
two nights and a mysterious young girl
trying to find a special crystal along
the way you'll find the typical final
fantasy dungeons items and secrets
classic characters like Vivi and Tara
will also make an appearance we'll see
what else the game brings when it
finally releases Sprave XV as's do this
summer but we don't have a definite date
yet that said you can pre-register at
final fantasy XV asst comm to unlock
some special items when the game does
release the game will also be playable
at square enix is III booth so expect to
hear more soon and for all the final
fantasy news you're already in the right
place
Oh